[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  spinning like [ __ ] today man let's go to  me  [Music]  hey supposed to be around here [ __ ] up  [ __ ] Sheryl Crow looking bubble this  is awesome  there be no garlic that smells about  Micallef or they're so cute  can we get the eggs before guys become  dicks you think you're pretty cool  they're ghetto ass friends you good  you think you're tough and [ __ ] give  this little [ __ ] kid a lot of the  time you feel like our lives are the  worst  but think of you looking anybody else's  closet you ain't trade your [ __ ] for  their [ __ ] so let's go that's why we  ride up he's some food  that does to somebody's spirit  see me what the [ __ ] are you doing  Stevie buggy is saying  [Applause]  you  you